but first up he is a professor of
linguistics at columbia university whose
new book is called nine nasty words
english in the gutter of ben now and
forever you can find his commentary on
substance.com and i don't mind saying
he's one of my heroes john mcwater is
over here john
i mean that no
we don't we don't touch anymore john
[Music]
i'd like to touch you because i'm such a
fan of yours i must tell you i'm just
good to hear bill oh i am
i i hope some of your friends were more
mutual friends have told you that over
the years that you know i admire you so
much not just because you're a voice of
common sense
but it takes guts these days to be a
voice in common sense
i think you know i don't i don't think
of myself as brave because what i really
am is a failed lawyer and my issue is
just that
if things don't make sense to me then i
just want to try to make sense of it and
i want people to understand what i mean
and this is the thing
if you are a good black person you're
often told that when it comes to certain
race issues you're supposed to not
quite make sense and that you're
supposed to deal with a certain kind of
word magic
i have never felt it i've always thought
i'm black and i would like that to make
sense too
and that's why i end up looking brave
when really i'm just obsessive
well
well what i what i get so much from
listening to you and reading you is that
you feel
condescended to which
i feel like that that is
especially lately yeah right and i i
see i see that all the time and i don't
know wonder i i do wonder why that's not
more in the dialogue we have what it's
the strangest thing like you read a book
like and yeah we're going to have to be
specific
white fragility which basically says
that black people
are these hot house flowers where
everybody has to tiptoe around us
and you know we're always crying and
we're always angry and we're just so
very very very delicate
i don't feel like that person that book
is talking down to me as far as i'm
concerned
it really should be called black
facility yes yes it should be used to
keep tables from wobbling that is the
only use
for that book and yet
you look on facebook and you have people
saying i'm doing the work
and reading this book and i think to
myself they are doing the work
of making me into a perfect idiot right
and yes why don't more of my fellow
black people feel that way and it's
because
of a very human thing which is that it
is a very human thing
to take on the victim identity all
people do it we've all known people like
that
a way you can do it if you're a black
person and all of us need to grab onto
something sometimes
is to read a book like that and think
yes i need to be treated that way
and i am going to start actively parsing
it that way
because i don't think people realize
what silly
babies books like that make us look like
so something something needs to be said
right but i mean to be fair i think
most black folks do agree with you it's
just the ones the people black and white
who are on twitter quite frankly yes yes
i know when i say these things it's not
just me and coleman hughes and glenn
lowery and two or three other people if
it was something like that i wouldn't
say
hey look at the way we weirdos feel it's
that i've been
black pretty much for 55 years and i
know how
black people feel right and i always
think this certain sliver of people in
the media
in academia they're you know they're
often much smarter than me but that is
not
the representative view and so for
example if you're going to read
how to be an anti-racist that is not the
general black view of things that should
be re it's like the bible
that book if you must read it should be
read as
literature rather than as scholarship
that's not general and yet we're told
that somehow
we have to accept these sorts of things
as the black view and you'll see it on
twitter
a black person will write on twitter you
have to listen to the black people who
are the real black people the black
people who black people listen to no
no there is a great deal of diversity in
the black community and i can tell you
it is not the default
in the black community to think of
ourselves as pathetic
yes we can't has never been the slogan
for black america and it's not now
you